dank einer vielzahl an qualitativ
hochwertigen youtube tutorials sind in
der lage uns komplexen aufgaben zu
stellen wie zum beispiel einen fernseher
reparieren
den quellcode für eine website zu
schreiben oder ein sehr kompliziertes
gericht zu kochen
aber was ist mit den einfachen dingen
des lebens was es mit brot schmieren
staubsaugen oder sich die hände waschen
dafür gibt es jetzt tutorials von dem
wir dachten dass sie eigentlich niemals
nötig wären aber anscheinend immer noch
leute gibt die zu dumm zum scheißen sind
brot schneiden
schneiden sie mit einem scharfen messer
eine scheibe brot abnehmen sie jetzt ein
weniger scharfes messer und streichen
sie über die butter streichen sie jetzt
mit dem begüterten messer abwechselnd
links und rechts über das brot lecker
staubsaugen nehmen sie ihren staubsauger
lassen sie die schwerkraft den rest tun
drücken sie auf an und lassen sie nach
vorne hinten und zur seite über den
boden gleiten sauber händewaschen nehmen
sie ihre schmutzigen hände und streichen
sie langsam von vorne nach hinten über
ihre katze diesen vorgang können sie
auch wieder holen oder sich sogar eine
zweite katze dazu
das ist ein ernst hier
du weißt doch dass ich die katzen lady
auf aber nichts aber schon zum dritten
mal zeigst du dir dein auf mit den
katzen videos man gar nicht zu
diskutieren
jetzt ist das video auch zu ende keine
kasse darf nicht mehr